So Donald Trump has become completely obsessed
with democratic presidential candidate Michael
Bloomberg.
And it's starting to get weird.
And we've been covering this for a little
bit.
For the last several weeks, Donald Trump has
seemed sort of triggered by Michael Bloomberg,
Michael [inaudible]
Bloomberg, putting out an ad about Trump's
golfing in which he used some, uh, unflattering
pictures of Donald Trump, Donald Trump, uh,
looking, uh, obese in the pictures that Michael
Bloomberg's ad used.
And Trump very much didn't like it and the
last 24 hours have seen Donald Trump devote
other than time devoted to pardoning people
convicted of various types of corruption.
Trump has devoted a lot of the last 24 hours
to tweeting and sharing videos and doctored
images of Michael Bloomberg.
His Twitter feed is simply riddled with the
stuff and Trump is becoming privately obsessed
with Michael Bloomberg.
Michael Bloomberg of course, will be debating
tonight his first debate in the democratic
primary and we will see whether the stop and
frisk stuff comes up or the leaked or publicized
audio.
We don't know, but what is very clear is that
Donald Trump is extremely distraught and obsessed
with Michael Bloomberg.
This started yesterday with another one of
his many Mike Bloomberg rants were Donald
Trump said, quote, what many Mike is doing
is nothing less than a large scale illegal
campaign contribution.
He is spreading money all over the place,
only to have recipients of his cash payments.
Many former opponents happily joining or supporting
his campaign.
Isn't that called a pay off?
Many is illegally buying the Democrat nomination.
They are taking it away from Bernie.
Again, many Mike major party nominations are
not for sale.
Good luck in the debate tomorrow night.
And remember, no standing on boxes.
The standing on boxes thing is funny, but
consider the hypocrisy here that when Donald
Trump ran in 2016 Trump bragged about how
he was funding his own campaign.
He was rich, he's got money, he's funding
his own campaign.
So he's immune from the demands of donors.
And now Michael Bloomberg is funding his own
campaign and Trump says it's illegal.
You can be for or against the system of campaign
finance that we have.
I'm against it vociferously.
So, but Donald Trump is criticizing Michael
Bloomberg for doing exactly the same thing
that he did in 2016 the difference is Bloomberg
has way more money.
That's quite frankly, the real difference
between Trump and Bloomberg and it seems to
be very triggering to Donald Trump.
Now, after this, Michael Bloomberg tweeted
to Trump, why do you want to run against Bernie
so badly?
To which Donald Trump replied many.
Mike, no, I would rather run against you.
At this point, Trump switched from tweeting
words about Mike Bloomberg to re tweeting
doctored images and fake videos of Bloomberg.
This is the president and he's spending his
day retweaking memes and videos of a possible
upcoming political opponent starting by re-tweeting
a picture of Michael Bloomberg's head, photo-shopped
onto a little kid's body on a debate stage
next to all the other candidates.
Again, going on this idea that Michael Bloomberg
is, is short.
Um, and then slightly later in the day re-tweeting
a video of Michael Bloomberg doctored to look
like Bloomberg isn't tall enough to see over
a lectern while speaking in public somewhere
unclear if Trump has realized that this was
a doctored video.
I don't know that they actually care.
Why do you think that Trump has become so
obsessed with Michael Bloomberg?
Is it that Bloomberg is so much richer than
Donald Trump?
Is that, that Bloomberg is actually spending
his own money and his ad spend is pushing
Trump to have to think about spending way
more than he wants to and probably isn't actually
interested in doing?
Is it a New York rivalry?
Bloomberg and Trump.
Trump, the New York businessman of Bloomberg,
the former New York, a city mayor.
Is it that Bloomberg is more successful as
a business person than Trump and doesn't have
the multiple bankruptcies?
I don't know what the answer is.
I'm not a Bloomberg supporter.
I'm not defending Bloomberg in any way, but
what I want to understand, understand is why
is it that Donald Trump, Trump has become
obsessed with Michael Bloomberg, triggered
by every new ad that Michael Bloomberg puts
out there and focused so heavily on Michael
Bloomberg.
Let me know what you think.
I'm thinking out loud here.
I don't know the answer, but I want to hear
from you.